Let's talk about 2020 polling.
Okay.
It's been weeks since I talked about the Democratic
primary polling.
Partially it's because I was gone all of last
week, but partially it's because we've not
been following it super closely at this point,
but we're now getting close to the start of
the Democratic primary debates.
Those start next month.
And at this point there are some really clear
and defined trends in 2020 Democratic primary
polling and the trends are for better or worse,
Joe Biden is leading but not by as much as
he was at the beginning of May.
Uh, Bernie and Elizabeth Warren have solidified
their second and third place positions.
Camilla Harris and peed booted judge or kind
of trading back and forth for the fourth place
position.
And then they're just like, are a whole bunch
of candidates who can't even break one or
1% or 2% who are effectively done and have
no chance.
So I want to go through this in order and
let's see kind of what we're left with at
the end.
First of all, the Green Line, if you are watching
along with me here is Joe Biden's polling
and I'll describe it in case you're listening
and not watching Joe Biden's polling hit a
high average of more than 40% early in May
and it's now sort of cooled off to just under
35%.
So Biden has lost somewhere around a six or
seven points depending on the poll you look
at over the last three to four weeks.
The question is, is Biden going to keep trailing
off or will he stick around 35%?
Uh, the progressive wing of the left is saying,
the more people know about Joe, the more his
support is going to erode because people aren't
going to like what Joe Biden is about.
That's a possibility.
Um, it also could be that there was some initial
enthusiasm behind Joe that is just kind of
a falling off now.
Okay.
So that's number one.
Number two, you'll look at the light blue
and the brown lines on this image that's on
screen.
Those are Bernie and Warren.
And I'll describe to you what's going on there.
Bernie was immediately hurt when Joe Biden
entered the race, and you see that when Biden
hit his high of around 40 plus percent, Bernie
hit his low, but he since recovered and Bernie
is now pretty solidly in second place, pulling
an average of just over 16%.
Now, Elizabeth Warren, on the other hand,
as I told you a couple of weeks ago, has been
slowly and steadily growing her support.
And it's now at a campaign high.
She's moved from being kind of in the 5% area
to seven to 8% in most polls.
She's now averaging right about 10% behind
Bernie Sanders, but not drastically.
So.
So let's now look now that we've seen who
the three front runners are, let's look at
who's done and has no chance the front runners.
Clearly Joe Biden, Bernie Sanders, Elizabeth
Warren behind them, and then there's the second
sort of many tier of candidates, which is
Kahmilah Harrison, Pete, Buddha, judge Harris
averaging about 7% booted, judge averaging
about 6% now the people who have no chance
and are getting no traction and will likely
start dropping out soon after the debate start
are the folks who are under 1% for sure and
a lot of the people under 2% as well.
Okay, so under 1% and have no chance whatsoever.
Tulsi Gabard Bennett Bullock who you may not
even have heard of, Hickenlooper, Seth Moulton,
Bill de Blasio, John Delaney, Kirsten Gillibrand,
Marianne Williamson, Tim Ryan, they're all
under 1% they just have no chance.
Okay?
I'm not telling them to drop out.
I don't really care one way or the other.
They're just non factors.
They're done and I don't even know that there's
that much attention to be paid to their prospects.
Then you have the one to 2% range.
Okay?
You've got Andrew Yang there, you have Julio
on Castro, you have Amy Klobuchar who are
between one and 2%.
They're also realistically done, but if you're
at 2% you can sort of justify staying in a
little bit longer.
I know that early I said I liked Andrew Yang
and I still like Andrew Yang.
I know that three months ago he had like a
hypothetical path to the nomination.
If he continued building support.
I'm not calling him done now.
I mean he's over 1% but if he doesn't get
to like three or 4% after the first debate,
I don't know how he justifies staying in and
then caught in this kind of no man's land
at more than 2% but less than anything significant
are Cory booker at 2.2 and Beto O'rourke at
3.8 I think they're also both done, but that's
enough support to keep raising money.
Keep raising your public profile by, by staying
in.
So that's my assessment right now.
If you disagree with me on any of this, let
me know politely.
Ideally, if there's someone in the under 1%
area that you think has a shot, tell me who,
and tell me why.
If there's someone who's pulling more than
3% and you do think they should get out right
now, tell me who and tell me why.
And if you think that there is someone who
isn't doing well, but as soon as they get
on the debate stage, they are going to be
so impressive to the voting public that they
will rock it up into at least the seven, eight,
or 9% range.
Tell me who, and tell me why people will be
so impressed with their debate skills.
We'll follow up.
We'll do a poll on the Youtube Community Tab
about this and see where our audience is on
a lot of these candidates and issues.